[Musique]
voir mes petits amis
n'ayez pas peur c'est le taux net et
nous sommes
que ce que vous dit pas trop pour nos
vieux
[Musique]
jeu dit il y avait du tonnerre
le rien entendu le jeu du culv ya du
tonnerre
[Musique]
j'espère que tu n'as pas peur au droit
chemin
[Musique]
on dépêche toi
ici bas
ne restez pas près de la fenêtre les
enfants cela tomberait à tromper mais
c'est pour l'instant peu de nouveaux cas
la chose toi d'être dans le ciel un
ducati c'est clair
[Musique]
j'avais déjà dit que j'allais papa papa
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce n'est pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous nous fermer sept feux cette fenêtre
ou où je me
demande pas trop ce soir je dors ici
ouf il était il de te
ils étaient tous
je n'arrive pas trop
un petit verdot j'arrive
merci l'epa peut
demain
venu nicolas fait pour asma bonnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà l'orage est terminée nounours
est vraiment un gros nigo qu'en
pensez-vous les enfants ou où on y va
papa papa pas trop en route mon bon
nounours bonne nuit les petits allez
sagement vous coucher est fait de deux
bouts bobo bourrin
[Musique]